awareness is key when it comes to
gynecologic cancers we spoke to a local
doctor from Intermountain Healthcare the
sponsors of the segment to learn more on
risk factors and prevention
hi I'm Dr Anika vizcarra I'm in OB GYN
generalist with Intermountain Healthcare
in Las Vegas at our Women's Health
clinic and I'm here to talk about
gynecologic cancers today
so when we talk about gynecologic
cancers we're mainly talking about
uterine cancer especially endometrial
cancer ovarian and cervical cancer
endometrial cancer is the most common
gynecologic cancer in the U.S with an
estimated 65 000 new diagnoses per year
and about 12 000 deaths from this cancer
per year the average age of diagnosis is
over the age of 60 typically it affects
post-menopausal women but with certain
risk factors can affect younger women
occasionally so risk factors of
endometrial cancer are increasing age
especially postmenopausal obesity
meaning body mass index of greater than
or equal to 30. history of and ovulation
or not ovulating every month some
protective factors are of course
maintaining a healthy lifestyle BMI as
well as potentially some of the
contraceptives including birth control
pills and specifically the hormonal
intrauterine device or IUD some symptoms
of endometrial cancer are specifically
post-menopausal bleeding because any
type of bleeding out after menopause is
abnormal so definitely let your doctor
know about those symptoms as well as
some other non-specific symptoms like
pelvic pain pain with intercourse or you
know abdominal bloating or swelling so
some risk factors for ovarian cancer our
age with diagnoses rarely happening
before the age of 40. family history or
genetic predisposition to ovarian cancer
obesity not having any prior pregnancies
in the past as well as infertility and
use of infertility medications for more
than a year
some protective factors for prevention
of ovarian cancer are use of birth
control pills for at least five years as
well as personal history of the removal
of Fallopian tubes and or ovaries or
prior non-cancer indications and last we
have cervical cancer so cervical cancer
used to be one of the most common
gynecologic cancers worldwide however
with the start of screening such as the
pap smear as well as HPV or human
papillomavirus vaccination that number
has decreased in the United States
there's about 14 000 new diagnoses
occurring each year with the majority
being in women between the ages of 35
and 44 and about 4 000 deaths from
cervical cancer each year so some risk
factors for cervical cancer the main one
really is human papillomavirus infection
which occurs with skin to skin contact
including sexual contact there are two
there are many different strains of HPV
and the lowest risk types cause genital
warts with the high risk types being the
ones we are most focused on for cervical
cancer as they are the ones that cause
cervical cancer other risk factors
include not getting your Pap screenings
or HPV screenings regularly or as
directed and also smoking
thank you to Intermountain Healthcare
for sponsoring this segment for more
information head to
intermountainhealthcare.org Nevada we'll
be right back